winter is coming let's start talking
spoilers
game of thrones season three season
overview you've hopefully tuned in for
my episode by episode breakdowns which
were spoiler free this one we're talking
the whole thing and you know what we're
gonna deal with the elephant in the room
the red wedding i kind of want to start
by saying that it was not as shocking to
me as i wish it had been i kind of blame
hbo for this because it was about eight
months between the last episode of game
of thrones season three airing and when
the thing became available on blu-ray
and i actually got my hands on it eight
months is damn near impossible to be
able to avoid spoilers
when something is becoming such a
massive part of the pop culture i did my
best and i didn't know exactly what was
gonna happen but you know what you give
me that much time i'm gonna put two and
two together people don't get that upset
unless somebody important is dying and
then i figured i was gonna be multiple
people thanks to south park's little
three-part spoof where they had their
george r.r martin character say you're
mad that i killed everyone at the red
wedding so it's like oh great so now
multiple people are gonna die it was
funny south park but i'm still annoyed
with you so when i actually got to the
red wedding i was actually slightly
surprised at how few major characters
ended up getting killed that said i was
not prepared for how brutal that was
gonna be oh my god i can only imagine
what it was like for people who had no
idea was coming unfortunately i kind of
did so let's get over the shock and
let's talk impact to call this a game
changer is a massive understatement this
completely changes what you think the
show's going to be i mean based on the
first season even the first two seasons
you would think game of thrones is
basically about the starks there's more
going on than them of course but they're
our initial lead into this world we
follow ned stark and his family even in
season two yes there's more all this
stuff going on but we always keep coming
back to the stars they're our anchor
they're our foothold and so the feel
that we get for the story is like this
is the story struggle for the iron
throne told
through the stark family
well
no
no because they're pretty much all dead
there's still a few of them around but i
think a big part of the point of the red
wedding was to go no this is not about
the starks this is not the starks versus
lannisters this is bigger than them so
stop focusing on them what do they do
they remove the distraction when the
stark's gone now you can't help a look
at the big picture like the fact that
there are freaking ice zombies coming
down from the north and you got dragons
on their way up as well which in
hindsight the things called the song of
fire and ice dragons fire white walkers
ice
of course it's bigger than the starks
but when you've got something that
massive and that's shocking that's a
really hard needle to thread i mean
i have no doubt there are probably some
members of the irons who just tuned out
after that thing like this is too much
this is too harsh this is too brutal and
what i tuned in and thought i was
getting and this is something else all
together but
i don't personally know anyone who tuned
out after that which to me says
they did that just right they took this
massive brutal
narrative breaking event
and make it work i mean it still hurts
to watch but
it works and it keeps everything going
you don't suddenly go oh well they
killed all the characters they're like
i'm not tuning in anymore no instead you
just keep going you go oh my god now
what
truly nobody is safe
i can now talk a little bit more freely
about some of the romance singles that
were bugging me too because i didn't
name any of them specifically the one
that drove me crazy was jon snow and
egret it was just so predictable and so
generic is so freaking young adult novel
series junk however i do kind of love
the fact that the season ends with her
shooting him in the back
repeatedly that was awesome i'm not sure
it was worth what it took to get us to
that moment but that was pretty awesome
now the other three romantic pairings
that annoyed me when i talked about the
four romances going on in the bear and
the maiden fair you had tyrion and his
i'm gonna call her his mistress she's
just annoying at this part all she does
is [ __ ] and moan and wine and she's not
really bringing anything to the table
anymore so she's starting to bug me and
she hadn't up to that episode but her in
that episode crammed in with all the
other romantic stuff i just i just
couldn't take it then you had rob stark
and his new wife which i
i never really bought in the first place
not that the chemistry wasn't good it's
like how stupid are you that in the
middle of this war going on you're gonna
focus on this really you got bigger
things to worry about buddy so whenever
it focused on the two of them i was like
dude plan a battle something get ow
though of course we all know how that
ended the last one was brienne of tarth
and jamie now i've actually gotten into
arguments with people because they will
attest to me that that is not a romantic
pairing at all and it's based on mutual
respect it's more about camaraderie it's
not really about romance well you know
what i don't buy that because i have no
doubt in my mind that if brienne of
tarth was a man jamie would not have
come back and rescued her
him
it's her but it would have been him if
it
whatever he wouldn't have gone back
we've seen him just rip through people
of all kinds people who have been
innocent people he respected like ned
stark that has never stopped him before
it's never caused him to question his
morals the only time we see him do it is
with a woman you can't tell me that her
gender has no impact on that now fingers
crossed it never gets consummated and we
never go down that road but i i it's
still a vibe that i get from it maybe
i'm reading into it but given that it's
something i hate i it's weird that i'd
be reading that into it but it's
possible sure why not those were sort of
the major spoiler points with stuff that
i i wanted to talk about in more depth
and more detail that i didn't really
have the chance to do before you know
taking the season overall this was
probably the rockiest season for me so
far i mean season one just hooked me i
loved it start to finish season two was
still really awesome i mean it
introduced the magical elements a bit
more which i've talked about i'm not as
big a fan of as the as the more gritty
or real side of the show but i was still
good with it there was nothing that i
was majorly like um yeah that's not
working for me this season add a couple
of those things that said most of them
were short-lived have or have somehow
been reversed or mended so
i'm not going to say this is any sort of
jumping the shark thing or that the
show's losing its touch obviously
they're pulling from the book so there's
a lot of stuff that they have to deal
with that you know maybe if it was just
up to the producers they wouldn't go
that route but you know what they don't
have a choice they're basing it off a
book but i think and everything's just
being handled really well and i'm i'm
still crazy excited for this thing to
keep going so it wasn't the best season
but it was good and i am so excited that
i will get to watch season four as it
airs which means that i will be back
with episode by episode reviews as i see
the new episodes hopefully coming out
fairly closely to when the things air
but we'll see what i can do with a
compressed time frame but until then
this council is adjourned